using light in interior design as a
discipline that requires a lot of
technical know-how lighting fixtures
combined form with function and
influence the look of entire spaces
berlin gallery owner and designer
furniture dealer hans-peter yo home
finds light fascinating I think you can
never have enough light because it makes
something completely new out of a space
nor night changes spaces in the 1920s
representatives of the Bauhaus school
designed lighting fixtures was an
elegant simplicity that was in line with
their belief that form should always
follow function one of the most famous
designs from that era is the desk lamp
created by vilhelm wagon felt and car
jakob Yuka in 1924 in Vemma it's clean
geometric lines made the WG 24 an icon
of modern industrial designs is no
composites the only colors are those of
the materials themselves at the same
time every element of color has been
considered very carefully you notice
that the aim is not to hide anything to
celebrate technology technics every at
room light is an increasingly popular
subject for exhibitions people are
rediscovering classic designs and the
often utopian ideologies behind them one
visionary idea was this 1958 designed by
Denmark's Paul Henningsen a pH artichoke
features 72 reflecting blades that
ensure light is distributed ideally
that is a Zygon anta Artie Artie
shopping launched the so called
artichoke them by Paula Nixon is one of
the first examples of a lamp that
sculpts light it's cool to work for
mitten deformed is a blades that give
the artichoke its name a design so that
the gaze of the observer is never on the
light post at this village Donna that's
some iron and there you never get
blinded because the blades function as
reflectors later diesel Ameria as they
flick to on during the 1950s and 60s
Scandinavians led the way in lighting
design creating countless classics
including these lamps by Denmark's
verner panton Germany's Ingham Oliver
also established an international
reputation the most revolutionary
designs came from Italy such as the Arco
lamp by the caste Leone brothers many
models were made in very small runs and
are now collectors items covered as leaf
design lighting design is remarkable
because there was so much
experimentation it was only in the late
1970s that it was increasingly
commercialized and a dad came from Italy
the TCO was one of the first low voltage
halogen desk lamps it caused a sensation
on its launch in 1972 the designer was
Richard sapper
fifteen years later the Tolomeo lamp hit
the market it was created by Italy's
miquellee Dellucci and jean-carlo
fastener it came in a range of different
colors and today more than a quarter of
a century on it's still a hit as a sun
object physician Vic Lisa would feel
it's an object that fits in with just
about every kind of interior either oak
paneling or steel pipes the lamp fits in
everywhere because it adapts to its
environment
Gunston Kibum and paths technological
development influences design one of the
most significant inventions was LED
technology tiny light-emitting diodes
opened up radical new possibilities on
the creative front tobias cow is one of
many designers who specialized in it
because the light emitting elements are
so small you can come up with completely
new shapes you can build completely new
lamps and create effects that would be
impossible with regular bulbs it's
fascinating on death on pacinian
LEDs are tiny adaptable and
energy-efficient which means that one
day you'll probably only be able to find
conventional lightbulbs in museums
you